[Music]
you
for those of you who are watching this
throughout the world the umbrellas are
not because it is raining we're just
very sensitive to the Sun
you
so we're going to take you now to the
graduates look over at the large
projection screen and see if there's
anyone you recognize graduates can you
hear us wave to your family and friends
great now family and friends wave to the
graduates they're all waving listen guys
it's wet out here and you're all dry in
there so hurry on over
hello everybody we're back in Killian
Court where it's drizzling a little
harder but it's still a drizzle so we're
going to take you now to the graduates
welcome back to the ice rink Killian
Court I'm now standing here with Erika
Brown who's graduating today with a
master's in aeronautics and astronautics
and aroan Herron has graduated with a
dual degree with a master's in business
administration and a master's in real
estate development Erika what was the
most challenging thing you did while
you've been at MIT I think so far the
most challenging thing Marc has been
working with a group the Mars gravity
bio satellite it's interdisciplinary we
get to make science and engineering and
business and law and technology and we
get to work with an international group
of students which is absolutely
incredible
mit just opens so many doors like that
wow that sounds incredible in a room
what's your fondest memory of being a
student at MIT I have to say it must be
sailing on the Charles seeing the Sun
dappling the trees and the buildings of
MIT in Boston and you get to meet people
from all over MIT not just from the
departments that you're in so it just
memories of like that will stay with me
for the rest of my life it sounds
incredible
Erika is there anything you'd like to
share with your family and friends
before we process out there well I'd
like to say hi mom hi dad
hi Andy thank you so much for sitting
out there in the rain and cold I
appreciate you both being here all of
you dad I'm so glad I could come to your
graduation I'm great grateful that you
could be at mine Thanks and our own well
I think I reckon Center quite well mom
dad thanks so much for coming Yanni
especially glad you're here representing
the rest of the family I know what it
meant for all of you to come out here so
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the academic
procession led by the chief marshal will
now enter Killian Court
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the guests of honor
the Class of 2002
[Music]
[Applause]
and the faculty of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology are now declared
convened together with
[Music]
together with this assembly on the
occasion of the commencement exercises
of this institution for the conferring
of its degrees the stage assembly and
audience will please rise for the
invocation by Reverend John Visnjic and
remain standing to join the MIT
corollaries in the singing of one verse
of the star-spangled banner
let us pray together in our own voices
and in our many tongues we have
countless wonderful and mysterious names
for our God the source of all beings
Great Spirit the one who is never fully
known the one who is ever-present Allah
Yahweh the Christ names which are as
varied as this gathered community today
and so we invoke our God this day not
bound by any name or image and yet with
us in our celebrations together we are
all grateful for the occasion of this
commencement for our individual
accomplishments achievements and
fulfillments in our prayers we thank
those who have taught and guided us we
hold dear our families and friends we
lift our colleagues and partners in our
prayers and after this day we go to our
parts of this planet we call home there
and then we will continue to struggle to
learn how to live together as the people
of this world may all beings be safe and
free from harm
may we be dedicated with all of
humankind
to find peace joy compassion and justice
amen
[Music]
so that's why life's nice leave me
[Applause]
[Music]
although
[Applause]
[Music]
please be seated
I am pleased to welcome to the platform
mr. James D Wolfensohn president of the
World Bank Group and the Honorable
Michael a Sullivan mayor of the city of
Cambridge
mr. Wolfensohn will now give his address
chairman Dolloff president vest members
of the corporation the faculty the
administration graduands your families
and friends
let me first say how deeply honored I am
to be here in what is essentially a
family celebration a celebration for
each of you on your achievements a
celebration at a very important moment
in your lives a moment when you are
reflecting a moment when you're looking
forward I feel deeply honored to be here
particularly as when I came this morning
I recalled with my own personal pleasure
my first visit from Australia in the
mid-50s
when I came past this wonderful building
looking to buy a copy of Paul
Samuelson's book on economics to try and
help me get through a course a little
bit down the road and this was an
occasion for me when I for the first
time put reality to my expectations and
hopes derived in Australia about
academic excellence about opportunity
about a chance to come and work within a
great country and in a great community
and to do so
with the possibility of developing my
own career this is indeed a great
institution an institution that has
enormous achievements in sciences in
social sciences and achievements which
have been marked by many previous
commencement speakers and by the world
at large but it's also an institution
which is engaged very much not just on
its past achievements but on its future
and we at our institution feel very
privileged to have relationships with
you and in particular on what I think
may well be the most significant advance
that this institution will ever have the
advance in relation to the opening of
your courses in the MIT open course
in which we're engaged not just with our
African virtual University but hopefully
as the years progress in making possible
of the underlying knowledge experience
and education forces that there are in
this university let me say that from my
point of view working in the bank
dealing with the issues of development
that this contribution may well be the
greatest thing that you've ever done and
I congratulate you and applaud you for
the opening of this prospect not only to
this country but to the world I have
come here this morning as you might
gather a little bit nervous nervous
because of the reaction to the World
Bank nervous because I see being held up
grade cards with F on it I'm
particularly nervous about that I might
tell you because personally I got too
many of them when I went through
university and I thought that at this
stage my record would be forgotten and
to be reminded of it as I come here
today as a cruel blow so I would ask you
just as a better personal dignity if
you'd turn it the other
way it'll allow me at least to recognize
that in the last 40 years I've come some
distance I've come some distance not in
terms of academics but in terms of being
able to take some of the values some of
the experience that I learned in this
city and have had the opportunity to
apply it to a world that has been
ever-changing and different and it's to
that that I'd like to address just a few
remarks to you this morning when I came
to the United States over 40 years ago I
conceived of the world as a bipolar
place as a place in which there were the
rich and the poor a place in which there
was the developing world and the
developed world the north and the south
a world that was divided I conceived my
own career there's something that I
reviewed in essentially personal terms I
wanted to get a graduate degree I wanted
to deal with the issues of my own
personal poverty
I wanted to deal with the questions of
building a career and I also thought
because I came from a distant country
and I knew just a little about
development that it was the right thing
the moral and ethical thing to take an
interest in those less fortunate in the
developing world I felt comfortable on
my graduation day as I'm sure you do
today in my achievements I felt
comfortable that I was behind a wall
that I had made it and that I was now
going to advance with all the sense of
confidence that you get from the sort of
achievements that you have remarkably
made this day and I thought of this
other part of the world as being a world
to which I would give part of my life
and then I'd come back and develop my
life
behind my wall I've learned in the last
seven years that the world is not
bipolar and simple but the sort of thing
that many of your students this morning
were talking to me about and caused some
reaction very often to my own
institution the notion of globalization
the notion of the shrinking of the world
has occurred most significantly in this
40 years since my graduation and today
the world is a different place for any
the thought that you could live behind
the wall September the 11th was a moment
when reappraisal had to take place this
was a moment when our country and indeed
the world were shocked and shaken to
recognize that events in Afghanistan
events in distant parts of the world in
events in Islam
events in those areas where people were
under pressure and disadvantaged were
not issues that could be conveniently
kept outside a wall but in fact were
issues that impacted on us that are part
of the developed world that the notion
of two worlds is no longer real there
whether it be environment or in health
or in crimes or in migration or in drugs
or in communications or in terror issues
in one part of the world become issues
in another part of the world and for my
own organization which focuses so much
on the question of poverty for our
organization the question is what is it
that is the question of equity and
social justice in that other part of the
world and how does it affect us in the
privileged world well if everyone had
doubts
September the 11th I believe made us
recognize the reality that was there on
September the 10th which is the poverty
somewhere is poverty everywhere that
global issues are local issues that
issues of development are issues not
just in developing countries but issues
for us the numbers are compelling we
have a planet of six billion people five
billion of the people live in developing
countries three billion of the people
live under $2 a day
and inequity is very clear I have just
come back from a trip to East Timor
Mongolia China the Middle East through
Central Asia each of these countries is
different but each reflects a sense of
inequity uncertainty although a
burgeoning area of hope for many people
but for all too many the question of
inequity finds its finds its evidence
and finds its manifestation in hostility
in reaction in a sense of abandonment
and that is an issue not just for those
countries it's an issue for us and as we
look forward to the lifespan that you
will have of the next 2530 years at
least our world becomes a world of eight
billion people seven billion people will
be in the developing and transition
economies twenty-five to thirty years
from now this is not a static situation
this is a situation where the five
billion has twenty percent of the global
assets and earnings and it's not a
situation that can continue it's a
situation which is essentially unstable
and it's not a distant issue and so my
message to you today is really a single
and simple message it's a message to say
to you
that whatever you judge of institutions
like the bank or contributions of people
of my generation your challenge is the
challenge of planetary equity your
challenge is the challenge of taking the
experience that you have had of the
education that you've had of the careers
that you're seeking to build and view
them not through the lens of a world
that exists behind a non-existent wall
but to look at your future as a world in
which your aspirations your dreams are
interdependent with those less fortunate
wherever they are it is not an issue you
can avoid it's an issue that you not
only Congrats but to which you have been
trained to advance let me give you just
one minor example drawn from a different
institution and try and put in
perspective what you've learned I was in
Georgia with a graduate recent graduate
in the field of development and
agricultural technology we visited a
farmer in a field and this rather
confident young man getting out of the
car went to the farmer and in pretty
good Georgia and said to him if I can
tell you how many sheep are in your
field will you give me one and the
farmer an equally good Georgian
responded yes I'll be glad to and my
young graduate friend looked around and
with a quick review said there are 873
sheep in your field and they're healthy
and the farmer said that's the most
amazing thing I have ever seen you're
correct
take one they bent down picked up an
animal started walking to the car when
the farmer said to him sir if I could
tell you which university you went to
would you give it back and my colleague
said yes he said well you went to
Harvard and he said you're right how did
you know he said well you picked up my
dog and my concern my concern ladies and
gentlemen is that you don't pick up the
dog that you use your education with
humility with openness with concern
because the issue of poverty the issue
of development the issue of equity is
your issue you cannot avoid it it is the
issue of peace and you all of you here
have been trained to make our world a
better place I have great confidence
that you will do that and I hope that as
you go forward you will give thought not
to the World Bank but to the issue of
equity social justice poverty and peace
thank you so much
[Applause]
now mr. Dhillon son of Arachne president
of the graduate student council will
give a salute to MIT from the graduate
student body following this mr. su Deb
d'lai president of the president of the
senior class will present the class gift
to president vest after which the
president will deliver his charge to the
graduates
dear graduates
let me first congratulate you on
completing an incredibly challenging
journey and for meeting the very high
standards of this institution well done
now I'm sure there were no doubt many
individuals that helped you along this
journey parents family friends and of
course MIT faculty and administrative
staff I would like to urge let's take a
moment now to all stand up and
acknowledge the contributions of those
all those who helped us by applauding
them please join me thinking it has been
a great privilege for me to have
witnessed your enormous potential be
through performing your cutting edge
research in topics ranging from labor
relations to Environmental Policy micro
electromechanical systems to silicon
biology or through your invaluable
contributions as teaching assistants you
graduating masters MBA and PhD students
have contributed a lot
to MIT and beyond in fact your
contributions extend well beyond
academics and research all of you
graduating today have played a critical
role in building and sustaining the
community that we call MIT more
significantly you have helped charter
the future direction of MIT in student
life especially at a time when a lot of
changes were necessitated in all you
have demonstrated tremendous leadership
and courage and now you move on to take
on leadership roles beyond the bounds of
MIT you are the leaders of tomorrow and
leaders who will bear great
responsibility and many will look at
your leadership and as we know well we
do not live in a perfect world poverty
global warming insecurity and many other
issues afflict us you will have the
challenge to address these issues while
working on these and other challenging
issues and living your daily lives I
would like to urge you to do do one
thing and that is to be considerate of
others as well
let's always try to remember that the
world we live in is made up of ourselves
and those around us this is very
significant as every action and decision
you make in future will impact everybody
around you those close by and far away
if we care about those around us with
the same compassion as we care about
ourselves the problems and the barriers
we face today will be minimized let us
use the privileged positions that we are
in now to reach out to those not as
privileged remember let's partake in the
opportunities that lay ahead of us and
available for us today for the sake of
one thing and that's betterment of life
now as you embark on your careers we
hope you'll be forward-thinking
and also don't forget where you've been
do you consider giving back to MIT in
ways you can and future generations will
be forever grateful for you just like
you are today
finally I congratulate you again for
your great achievements here at MIT and
I wish you all the best in your future
endeavors
thank you
[Applause]
everybody said cheese now that that's
out of the way
it's not every day that we experience so
momentous an occasion as MIT
commencement it's not every day that so
many of our close loved ones come
together to celebrate with us the
culmination of four incredible years and
it's not every day that the senior class
of 2002 graduates from MIT here in it is
my desire to relate to you esteemed
members of the MIT community special
guests and especially to the class of
2000 to a tale that you don't hear every
day told to me by a member of our class
who asks to remain anonymous
Jake P sucker Department of mathematics
and biology he asked me to keep this
tale in strict confidentiality which is
why I'm only going to tell the tale
to 12,000 of my closest friends during
an afternoon in the fall term of our
freshman year when we all entered MIT
our Jake snuck in a president vest
office on a mission to steal something
from our beloved Institute president
spotting an IV plant in the corner our
brave hero snatched the plant left a
hastily scribbled ransom note and ran
away
gallivanting down our infinite corridor
now let me just pause here and remind
you president vest that if for some
reason
you do not physically hand Jake his
diploma he will not graduate from MIT
for four years Jake has cared for this
plant and over the course of four years
throughout our entire MIT experience
through all the problem sets exams and
activities that plant has grown from a
small house plant into a large branching
ivy with tangled shoots in every
direction long stems grasping for
surrounding support constantly searching
for the sunlight when I first heard this
tale three weeks ago I was struck by two
things first that members of our class
always find interesting things to do at
their time second as I stand before you
today it is this same tangled weaving
growth and change that ironically I have
seen in all of you that comes to my mind
when I reflect on our four years at the
Institute I ask you now to think back to
our freshman year when we first entered
campus remember how excited we first
were just to be at MIT we be we took
multiple tours of campus we became
caught up in the excitement of
orientation we even phoned home to tell
our parents that there was a Burger King
in the Student Center we started to
think that life couldn't get much better
then the first day of classes began and
we began to ask ourselves why did I
choose MIT over state school like
Harvard somehow someway we worked
through physics calculus and we survived
then they took us off of past no record
but slowly we learn to survive our
second year here as well we began to
realize how valuable our academic and
personal experiences here really were we
became involved in research at our
academic departments a myriad of
activities and I believe we begin to
create for ourselves and the rest of MIT
a community that year the Leukemia rally
that we held for one of our own
classmates showed the world how
committed we were at a service and to
each other by the time our third year
came around we were ready to face any
challenge that MIT could throw at us we
wanted to take more classes we took
pride in doing extra work it became a
badge of honor to be logged on to Athena
our computer network for three
consecutive days on three different
computers all the while our community
flourished I believe the reason that we
were able to trudge through these
experiences and come out alive was
because we did it together
now in our senior year we have begun to
realize how important we are to each
other we have had to depend on each
other and not just for answers to
problem sets we have had to help each
other face a difficult world after
September we came together to support
each other to rebuild our hope and to
keep hope alive the common thread that I
see whether we're talking about a
leukemia rally our response to national
tragedy or even saving the dot a small
circle of grass on the east side of
campus is that our community has always
been our greatest strength it is no
surprise to me that as a community we
send forth to the world roads and
Churchill scholars all American Olympic
caliber athletes talented musicians
students have begun service programs in
the third world
students who accept academic and
professional positions at world-renowned
institutions to me what distinguishes
the class is the 2002 spirit a
motivation to make a positive difference
wherever we are
for four years that's stolen ivy plant
blossomed into a thing of life and
energy what I hope to remind you
class of 2002 is that so did we we have
never stopped exploring we have never
stopped learning we have looked under
every Rock in every corner and in every
obscure MIT tunnel because we know life
is all around us
we have charted a tangled incoherent
spontaneous path for our lives changed
many things and along the way and
throughout it all we never stopped
searching for the sunlight over the past
four years I've noticed our passion for
living and as I look at each of you now
I am certain it's a passion that will
never die seniors here's to growing
living learning breathing loving may we
never stop our search for the Sun and
always remember to smile when we find it
Thank You class of 2002 now in following
MIT tradition I am proud to present a
president vest our senior gift to the
Institute funded entirely by seniors
this year our gift involves a senior
participation rate of 31% part of which
will be used to create the class of 2002
piece garden the garden to be created by
the new Stata Center for computer
science will symbolize our community our
strength and solidarity our values and
our commitment to serving the world
however I believe it also represents the
growth that all MIT students go through
while they are at the Institute
president vest if I might invite you to
join me at the podium in slightly
bending tradition a little I present you
with not one but two senior gifts we
have managed to acquire the infamous ivy
plant
that was stolen from your office so long
ago for four years the Institute has
taught us and allowed us to grow and we
give back to you the plant that belongs
in your office and the peace garden from
the class of 2002 thank you very much
professor finally I ask all of you
seniors to take off your brass rat look
at it but more importantly look all
around you throughout all the hard work
all the years these are the people that
got you through supported you these are
the people that you'll remember in the
experiences you'll take with you the
ring symbolizes all our struggles
struggles and our great class turn that
ring around let that MIT beaver face the
whole world
and remember seniors as I congratulate
you on a job well done
this day rain or shine belongs to us
thank you mr. July and mr. sim of
Arachne I will take good care of this
plant beginning by giving it a thorough
watering this afternoon I'm very
grateful for your gifts but more
especially for all that you and your
fellow students have meant to this great
institution we have for the past 10
years vested the responsibility for
weather at commencement in our crack
student weather prediction team and
Earth atmospheric and Planetary Sciences
this year we outsource tit
next year we return to our crack weather
prediction student group in Earth
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences at
this time I want to take particular note
of a group of remarkable individuals
with us today the members of the class
of 1952 you can recognize them you can
recognize them by their bright red
jackets at the moment well covered by
white plastic and also by a certain aura
of experience that they carry with them
as mr. Wolfensohn said the world has
changed greatly since their graduation
with all that they have witnessed in the
intervening years I am sure that they
could tell us much about what is truly
valuable in life and they could also
tell us about one thing that never
changes the pride that you can take in
knowing that you have earned a degree
from MIT to the class of 1952 welcome
and so we are gathered here once more in
Killian Court to celebrate
accomplishment heritage and passage we
are surrounded by parents families
friends spouses partners and children
who have supported and sustained you
through the years you will recognize
them today by their smiles brought about
by their great pride in your
accomplishment and no doubt by a sense
of relief to their bank accounts we all
are very grateful for what they have
given to us and we are particularly
pleased to have them joining with us
today here in Cambridge for your
commencement ceremony since you arrived
at MIT we have moved from the closing
years of the 20th century to the opening
years of the 21st we have moved from
predictions to realities during this
time
the end of science was proclaimed the
Internet bubble burst and we suffered a
national trauma at the hands of
murderous terrorists yet despite these
predictions in these realities this is a
time to sustain opportunity and openness
despite the current problems of our
world I believe this is in fact a time
for optimism I have about eight pages to
read to you about opportunity I'm going
to reduce it to one or two sentences in
deference to the weather science has not
ended it is transformed in wonderful
ways to create new opportunities for you
to serve the entrepreneurial spirit has
not died it will be reborn to build
vibrant economies for our nation and for
the world there is a wonderful field of
opportunity ahead of you nonetheless the
thousands of deaths suffered in New York
Washington and Pennsylvania as our
school year began have changed our
outlook in profound ways their
ramifications will be with us for years
to come
September 11th paved the way not only
for military responses it changed
instantly our relationship with the rest
of the world it challenged our very
concepts of citizenship civil liberties
and openness we will all struggle with
these matters together in the months and
the years ahead
they have no simple answers and they
hold grave dangers but they also provide
opportunities to think about how we
might better define contribute to and
achieve security for this nation and
this world as we consider opportunity in
the context of the post 9/11 world we
find ourselves asking questions
that have arisen time after time in
modern history to whom is opportunity
available and how open should our
society and our institutions be each
spring my wife Becky and I hosted dinner
in our home for the men and women who
are retiring from the ranks of the
Faculty of MIT these are always
extraordinary gatherings of talented and
accomplished colleagues they are the
people who have defined MIT indeed these
are the people who have defined their
scholarly and professional fields and as
I survey that room each spring I realize
how much MIT and indeed America have
benefited from being open to people from
all nations I think how fortunate we are
to spend our lives in an institution
that is based on meritocracy that is one
in which people are selected and
advanced based on talent and
accomplishment rather than wealth or
nationality now some might say that what
I am observing is the passing of an era
but I am simply seeing the end of the
intellectual migrations from Europe that
were associated with the turmoil of
World War two no it is much more than
that the sustained excellence of our
colleges and universities is due in very
large measure to the fact that we have
welcomed scholars from other nations
take for example the members of the MIT
faculty who have received the Nobel
Prize in recent years our MIT Nobel
laureates have included people born in
Japan India Mexico Italy and Germany as
well as the United States many of them
came to this country as graduate
students or consider our Institute
professors the dozen or so faculty
members who have achieved the highest
rank of the MIT faculty they were born
in the United States and in Belgium
Mexico Israel and China the fact is that
America has always been a land of
immigrants and we have long been a
nation of opportunity those who have
come here from around the world to study
have contributed mightily to our society
and our institutions many have stayed
and built our nation some have returned
to the land of their birth taking with
them knowledge and skills that they
acquired here but they also have taken
with them a better understanding of what
is good in this country in its people in
its democracy in its freedoms and in its
institutions and all contributed while
they were here to their fellow students
quality of learning and experience that
can come only from a campus that is
diverse in all of its dimensions as we
in this country strive to make all who
live here safe from those who would harm
us we should not let our fear close the
door to our own opportunity let us
recognize the cost to future generations
if we were to become too zealous in
tightening access to our universities
one of the terrible realities of these
times is that our very openness and our
technologies have been turned against us
but we must not react by casting aside
the very freedom and openness that
define what is good in America opening
our great research universities to the
best students and scholars in the world
is one of the best tools for spreading
democracy knowledge and human
understanding throughout the world up to
now in my view our federal government
has moved very thoughtfully and
judiciously in this regard it is
essential that they and the academic
community continue to work together to
enable sincere talented students from
around the world
pursue serious studies here that is the
American Way and let us also resolve
that our new technologies the Internet
and the World Wide Web will be used as
tools of empowerment and democratization
on a global scale next fall
as mr. Wolfensohn mentioned the MIT
faculty will launch its MIT
OpenCourseWare program a program that
will make the basic educational
materials for some 2,000 of our subjects
available on the web available to anyone
anywhere free of charge why do we do
this because we see it as part of our
mission to help raise the quality of
higher education in every corner of our
globe the program is based on the twin
values of opportunity and openness these
are values that have made our
universities and our nation strong they
are values that will keep our world safe
and strong and they are values that you
should treasure and protect as you make
your way in the world this then is my
charge to you our graduates take your
education your talent and your energy
and build us a nation and a world
community that consider knowledge a gift
to be shared a healthy planet place to
be cherished in human dignity and
opportunity fundamental conditions to be
enjoyed by all people men and women of
MIT I wish you Godspeed and the very
best of good fortune
[Applause]
thank you dr. das by virtue of the
authority delegated to them by the
corporation of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and on the
recommendation of the faculty president
vest will now present the following
degrees Bachelor of Science Bachelor of
Science Master of Science Bachelor of
Science master of engineering and the
advanced degrees for the School of
Science and the Whitaker College of
Health Sciences and Technology Provost
Robert Brown will present the advanced
degree for the School of Architecture
and planning the School of Engineering
the School of Humanities Arts and Social
Sciences and the Sloan School of
Management the first graduates to be
recognized are the class marshals who
already on the stage
recognition will now be given to the
officers of the Class of 2002 and the
officers of the graduate student council
who were seated on the stage sue Deb see
dawai president of the class of 2002 is
awarded the degree of Bachelor of
Science in brain and cognitive sciences
Sonya guard vice president of the class
of 2002 is awarded the degree of
Bachelor of Science in electrical
engineering and computer science
DeLonge Suniva ratner president of the
class of 2000 president of the graduate
student council is pursuing the degree
of Doctor of Philosophy manisha jith WA
vice president of the Graduate Student
Council it was pursuing the degree of
Doctor of Philosophy Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the School of Architecture
and planning who have completed the
specified degree requirements Bachelor
of Science in Arts and Design
James K alt advanced degree diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
School of Architecture and planning who
have completed the specified degree
requirements Master of Architecture at
maa Bernardo detie Yoshihisa K Amano
Jorge our Carbonell Matthew C Brown L
Arial embossed Oh Miguel Chacon Michael
V Gibson Carolyn B Gen Joseph c ho and
of the Gallagher soo om Christine L
goldrich Stephen C Jackson
Andreea J horse Ronnie Laura H Kim
Seanie M Campari me young can come
Julie H Coffman Paul age Kim Elizabeth s
Kwok edwin Kahlo Tina
Lin Jung Suk Lee Andrew jaelyn young Ali
Elizabeth P Newman Jennifer s Mac
Benjamin D rice Lena
m-matthew Nicole a Vlad Oh Keith be
mcklusky Amy K yang Nicole why Michelle
Bachelor of Science in planning Javon J
Bickerstaff Junko Nakagawa Halina W food
Stephanie Nussbaum cress sandy MP Julia
Oh Jonathan D read William II Pitts
the third Jeffrey C Roberts Amina rizvi
Bachelor of Science diplomas will now be
presented to students in the School of
Engineering who have completed the
specified degree requirements Bachelor
of Science in civil engineering
Isaac e Moses Manan H Shah Caroline M
Purcell
Matthew Jase immitis Bachelor of Science
in environmental engineering science
Arturo are under Zola Guzman Nathaniel
as scary
Lorraine II cable Kadena Sreenivasan
Nancy B Choi Daniel G's Steger Daniel
are Feldman monavie tamari and M are
bells Master of Science and architecture
studies Marcella angel Samper Christina
e Lopez Bernal Rosalyn SD amber Jay Oh
Pamela tank only Abigail s pop yanli
Matthew P van Hoorn Proheat are meander
otta Amy B Watson then M montón
Elizabeth ly ly Ruth Bauman Bachelor of
Science as recommended by the Department
of Civil and environmental
Engineering Melanie I Pincus
Gustavo Rodriguez Martin Warren see
ruder paul h slap of air scheme Bachelor
of Science in mechanical engineering
while in T about Ian s sheared right in
EM Alan David sees sledge Robert a Aaron
stone prana sued Lowell L Baker shampoo
our son Oran s Bernstein Singh chen-wong
Amanda my young Jennifer T Blondo w
Winnie w Wong Marjorie a Brevard XI and
Yi Mercedes the Costello Master of
Science in building technology yang Gao
Brian Ken
Master in City Planning James M Abrams
Alexandra H ciao Ryan P Allen Daniel s
Cho Diana Algar of yay Cisneros Alexis a
Bennett Kristen Bell Clements vanthu as
Bruce Oh Joshua our climb Catherine F
carton Jonathan a cold
Boyan hm Christian M Garland Sharon L
Chan Nicolas a DeMarco side LT Chang
Eliot's
F Drake Hilary s Chapman Kevin M
Ferguson Alberto and preschool Oh
Jennifer M humara Elizabeth Oh Curtis
Ibrahim I Fontaine Catherine ideas
Miyaichi and Gandhi
Michael G Donovan Christian D Garcia
rosemary see Dudley Veronica Garcia
Rosana
dude Zack Thomas H Glenfield jr. hope H
Fang
Eric M Glover
Eric Feldman Joshua a goal wins Akron s
Victor Charles Gonzalez jr.
Marissa Gaither Federico II Gutierrez I
should burn our cows Rao Richard M Hanna
Michael dealer ketchup OH
Harun sweet Antonio F Gonzales Luna
Maria Luisa is amis Kenneth R Goulding
mark and Jeanette's David s Greenblatt
konnichi row Jin Benjamin H Hudson
Alexis W Johnson zebra and Kumar Kiawah
Kendrick Esther jelly
Benjamin Kim Rachel el lo Gina Kim
Michael T Looney Jean young Kim
Ronald malice Kathryn em knock
Richard L milk David and Carter no way
Justin L - grant w Cristo feck Anna
Laura W no tiara
Nicholas a Kulkarni Laura are paisa
Kevin are Lang Tina
t pill Jennifer Lee George J Pro Akos
Rafael a mondo ha no Shahid and pun
Johnny Luke a Missouri Christina DeRozan
timothy peake McAvoy Emily see
Rubenstein David M Nicoletti
Chicago Sasson Lincoln T Neil Brian J
sham Wayne Daniel f o pilla Xiang Yun
Chao Louise M Otero Diaz Harold G Tucker
Maria M Otero Jesse D Williamson
Christina s Park
James W Wilson - Jay Park Leo RG Zion
Julio young master of science in urban
studies and planning way
leave Cynthia K Pereira master science
and media arts and sciences
Rahul Bhargav Rory P Peiffer Nell be
briar
Carla are peak nagura Robert seed Burke
Alexandra h po che
Angela Cheng benjamin GE powers Marco a
Escobedo Gonzalez my ease
Stephanie impressed her Benjamin T
fielding Piper Amir d rizal scheme
Timothy D Herzl Derek G R interconnect
ashish Kapoor Michael H Roberts Kuan
Hong Li Marcus Rodriguez Jorge you
Martinez are Aisha
Danielle Sandoval Marco a mandroid
Fonseca Daniel Santos
Makeda pashchenko Aaron J Schmidt
benjamin i Reznor abraham d Schneider
Arnon CP Pacquiao Maya sure Casey W
Smith
Adele G Smith Dana s Spiegel sudah j su
ramesh Sreenivasan Joshua snit Minh
Alexander Stoops Sophie Tarun Demetrios
a Vizio Vitas Mary Kay Thompson
James EU or Jose ain't Valda Vino's
master of science and real estate
development
pouchy su Alberto F mascara Doctor of
Philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
hola me day you are Joe saying lij
Weinberg richer deeper although I Kip L
Whittaker William J blue Terrence
Jeffrey V Wilson Maria Luisa they called
us Jimmy see whoo a caravan to trot
Roger yay
Robert cowherd bachelor science as
recommended by the Department of
Mechanical Engineering Daniel J Ben
a moon us AP do art Daniel J Bush Pedro
M purposive for us to our pre-owned
Elizabeth a duo sing in throughout Udo
vasilia see Hwang Yuri I even of Manuel
II Martinez
Connie shibaura sabrine s Muhammad Yi
Jung Gregory see Townsend
Mizuki kalibata Colette's
H Weisman Ling PACOM Jason s Jim Adnan Z
Martian Bachelor of Science in material
science and engineering
crystal our author lords and Bergeron
Sara CE Baron an EP drank brine F Bell
Jr Randall deep Pinkett Rafael bras
Frank J Pompeii Bo Yi Chang Jean a
Riesman Jason W Claude Louis A's fan Lee
Jeffrey J Colton William M Tomlinson jr.
Alexandra seed Ford Ming Zhang Leonard
Jay grant advanced degree diplomas will
now be presented to students in the
School of Engineering who have completed
the specified degree requirements master
of engineering in civil and
environmental engineering
Niraj Agarwal Vanessa L Hernandez Adele
oh honey
ulong L Shin Michael J Barack II carry
an egg way sock - Chihuahua cool
Elizabeth a Eamon hristos at SIA go-go's
Alicia M Jackson shahira a 13
Jimmy why Gia Andrew see Terraria
Kenneth g jo Yong Cheng ow Amy see Lin
Kirti Herrmann Daniel D Lowry hey Fang
Xiao Brad M McAvoy Carmen see Hudson
Trisha
M Montalvo
soon cake Wang grace asking Ashish s
Kulkarni pileinn X pang young age quack
Nina prochik Eric M lo ELISA
M Robbins jianzhang loan Tiffany s
Santos Luka Morgan T Lisa ace capital o
Roggeveen Iran Anya
Jade sorry Tommy ki Steven M Tobias
Natalya Oh leave a bachelor science as
recommended by the Department of
material science and engineering
Sarah Kay Perlmutter Marika our cool a
Poorna sir a panini Kevin Richards
Bachelor of Science in electrical
science and engineering Andrew I own
glory mod report bilang L&T a speck
Russell else peeler Daniel J Bedard
mark ace tire Jeremy T Braun Bora am
cocaine Yin a cow Osama we Aharon Judy
alchun
Kevin M Westerhof Judy why Ken Tasha
onion human Chi su yang why you Chris
roll H Troy Master of Science in civil
and environmental engineering bossom H
patch a teeny Felicia sea-cocks
Benjamin M Cheatham suparna does Daniel
B Collins
Timothy why done Giorgio's constantan
Edie's barest by Kirkman
Susan C done Kim a Solinsky
Beatrix Fidalgo Richard J Frank fotios
fotopolous sawmill J Gandhi Margaret
ain't pullin wider Brian D Goldberg
Jacqueline e hanky Daniel a good
takashi imamura zara
kanji koji ichimaru Daniel W Kwan
Valerie why Ivanova Ryan and Lang
Konstantinos colleague Rose Fred Xiang
yang li Arden Karaka Joseph H Levine
Christina cholera Daniel M levy Jean
Louise e locks am Eugene Jay Lim David s
Macomb Joseph Lewis Thomas s Monson
Christopher T lion Matthew be Olson
Gregory M behold de Braga is a handsy
and Masood Christian a sod Michael Jake
Mills melon Samaha Raymond Morales
takishi Sato Bradley see Ortloff Isamu
Suzuki Piaget's Panna pods Nabi Kate
ochre Eileen M kanoon Eric J Wanamaker
Peter are Rousseau master of science and
mechanical engineering
Amy B angel anand d sorrow t errand
first Majin the new Seth Wilson CN couch
and Matthew and Staubach Zhu Chen Chiang
Saen cadenza van Rijn Alberto J city
Donnie's kang ke Truong AMRO m3 Michael
H Vogel nadir farzana Jade P Wang Fareed
gonji risen Wang gennady golden stain
Ngati Wai Weissman sorry good level 18
yeesh a Brendan a Harley Amanda why
yiyang reginella see Hutchinson show how
you smack our generals Chongqing Joan
Maria I can we sell us
bachelor of science and electrical
engineering and computer science
basil why Alma for a Omar and Kundali
Jordan M alprin Ernest s Kim Alexandra
artola hukala L Masha Theodora Arviso
the third Suzy Jamie kwon do we re
Manuel a Balderas Michael L Palmer
Arencibia Laura L Proctor Jason M Bell
Greg a Radha Gary Terrell Bennett Clint
a rose Frank or Bentley Rhonda a
Saltzman John J Belle Epoque well the
third L&G Santoso John W Bostick
mohabbat k senior young Cohibas Gonzales
Chad a smut sir fernando Ceballos
Krishna and Shri Rama Derrick's each an
Byron M stencil Jeanette y Chen member
of the class of 2002 executive committee
Jeremy F Suggs Robert ccheng Yankers son
Winston D Cheng pre paddy varanasi
Catherine Beach in Alexis C Webber racy
Cheng
Andrea's our Wingert Denise be turn on
ik yoga Leo Club Vivian yung Chen Wei
Xiao Yu Jean Chu Lai so jonathan h qu
master of engineering in material
science and engineering able z hasting
Eric D Cohen Allison Hernandez Sharov
our day David and Cooper V jdv Lauren
see on Trevor s Donnell Alexander J
white shinning do Master of Science and
material science and engineering
Dinesh Bella Condren Christopher L
elledge Dini Berlin Jose a Esparza
Franco Laurieann Kensal Aaron o force ye
lamb Carlos a Garcia Benjamin P Nunes
Risa em Garcia Marquez Oliveira sorrow
Jake it's Owen Carolyn rim Carlos a
Gomez Reba
master of engineering and electrical
engineering and computer science
Michael L Arts Lucy Guan befo kado are
you know
parisa and Habibi Michael W Baker naira
Jairo
Hugo be bara James L Hardison Jason H
pal Matthew D Houseman
Igor L Velikovsky Elizabeth a Herbert
Alexander Vuckovich john c ho Jeffrey J
billing Clifford H Hodges Pedro Sifu
nose Rudy Rihan Ladera ROM Mark Boucher
Jennifer Huang Johan D Burgert dan it
Sarah Luciano
kostik NOLA Jairo Yoshi away Seema oh my
and chompin area Matthew T Jacobs Jolie
L Chang sheet all a Jane nielsie cheong
fatt Toliver Jeju Spencer Jade Firestone
aleena a comin at skaia Michael J
Friedman Christine a Karlovic I'm
Prakash Deena wali Carly M
no Rachel a greenstick Jonathan D kennel
Nicolas see Homer je s Kim
Nathan J miss James why night Joshua
Jacobs mark Q night Kyle a Jameson
Teresa h KO ng cow su Chun Quay Ronald a
Kapusta Pavel crap even Jung ask him Raj
Krishnan UJ a Kulkarni's chia hula jack
see Kwok Andrew a lamb
Dennis Wong Eric Larsen Derek s ma'am
Tian Locke jail ow
David Seely Simon s Lawrence G King Leo
Alan lazarevich Orlando W Leon Gary
Seeley
Justin men Ryan s ly ly quote Lynn
vanessa Lee eco T Lisa Wanda grace limb
she knew h lu m
Sara hung low we just dropped water
ego te Lisa Wandy Emery seal in shinu H
lubed can Lou ser hung low man way mu
yelena medic
Lorenzo fernando em Laura Lea
Rani G misra Rani ma a tuck Raymond a
Molnar Michael J McCarthy
paulkaiju rogue a Robert M McPhee
Christopher s Osborne Melissa H meow
Joseph S Fannin even Nicole a Ozma
calacas Daniel J Park R&D mahalik Jesse
and Pavel Matthew Dimas Ricky no shear
one petty gara aim evil the Miller tiara
Panipat Karen K Inge mark pipes
falou so L o Kuhn Sunday Terence see
pone ton Q fun Robert J Ragno Damian Oh
plumber Ravi and RAM Keystone set a porn
porn promo likud
[Applause]
Adam D Rosenthal
Christopher W Porter Nichols saturon
Gani Joshua see Randall
Jonathan M Saul's V Bob Ezrin garage and
so weak sighs - ah sigh son Jake a rail
hey son Santa corn Richard Emre demske
Sean J Sutherland Robert M read Edward T
Tolson Pascal F Rettig Amy Vandiver J
Cairo Benjamin n Vandiver John see Ron
Dhoni Thomas Thomas are Woodfin Ezra why
Rosen master of science and electrical
engineering and computer science
Joe um Chris say how reginald e Brian's
Regina Sam yung-chun Gustavo s Santos
Albert see ciao
Anant k Saraswat Adrian D chord duniya
know
Oh braids are shippin ovitch Lillian L
date Matthew W Schiller Laura M Durham
Matthew s cig Miller Amy and Englehart
Kinjo sham Edward a Phyllis Co Charles
c-sharp mark a Finlayson a shanshu
Michael J jeroni node re C Qi Nava Karen
m'gann's allas Valentin Ishwara case of
a Kumar Anika K Embry Frederick cistrome
Corey j-just Kolski
Naveen and soon Cavalli Theodorus K
constant kanopolis Daniel J Talavera
Thomas P cot wall C song - car and lean
Angela see took her re al ly Baratheon
Alexandra and Vasya
Allan K mu Marvin Velazquez Louis
Philippe Morin see Keith K wanna me
Lauren J O'Donnell Nath you H wash our
Mitra M Oh squeeze David II West James M
Perkins read a Williams auntie thumb
Jeremy Keith and Wong Ernest J pista
Terry Jr Jonathan s swung dentist a Kwan
jr. David P Woodruff Jason d Rennie
fishing
Alexandre de Salle Giano mean Anshu a TJ
shin milena Navya Makena Travis L
Simpkins Victor s young Michael P Slovak
Jennifer J you Eric be Sutter Sophia see
you did ski I Godfrey tan Nikolai be
Zelda Sheila Tandon autumn wise
young Aleta Tay beiges on Salem Timmy
sir Steven Jew Eduardo are Torres Jarrah
Bachelor of Science in computer science
and engineering
Philip be armor Kimberly G waters Jatin
nonny
Justin K Wuerffel I'm a tie Axelrod
Lina's Oleg Jeffrey are bender Master of
Science and chemical engineering
1c on Choi William T Blackwell so Shana
are gourd I'm Sarah tea bush a Master of
Science in chemical engineering practice
a Roth watch on an theremin Lauren H
Bradford Roger L IRA know Jordan see
Brewer Paul C Ayers
Matthew J Browne a street : t raro
Lawrence J Bruns Minh lino a Gonzalez
Timo Burkhard Marie J Heights Damien n
Burke Jacob a Johnson Jessie D Pilar
Meegan Oh Lamont
Joshua I came
Evan j p-- island Audrey Chang Heather a
stern Daniel check Master of Science in
ocean engineering Cherie a Cheng Sumida
Chakrabarty E&L Ingram Benjamin a
chambers
Zachary J malinovski we need W Chen Anna
P Michelle Phillip Cheng Master of
Science in naval architecture and marine
engineering Claudio karoli Priscilla P
Chun master of science in naval
architecture and marine engineering
naval construction and engineering
William II Duncan when Chun Chun David J
price Frederick W choy Todd e Whelan
Eric Geralyn Geralyn Master of Science
in ocean systems management afanasiev
Denise's Edmond M Chu alexandros
gorgeous Amy M Chu your just K Co callus
Jennifer K Chun master of engineering
and Aeronautics and Astronautics
Satsuki kasi tani Patrick M Cody master
of science and Aeronautics and
Astronautics Lawrence J basket John peek
ugly ah no Sarah E Bergstrom Edward
Cutler Sean D Bradshaw Matthew J
Craighead oral EF bristle let's Andrew s
crane Erica Elle Brown Douglas a Krieger
Carmen Carreras Paul a Crofton jr. James
P chase ROG s danda JH couching Deb P
descriptor Rebecca J daily Gregory D
Dennis Nathan P Diller Glenn K Iguchi
David do Gail Roderick a Ferguson the
fourth Karelian G Dyer yes Chesky
Fisher Anthony D Evans Catherine ke
phool Simon W Evans kattiline a Franco
Christopher Gould stone William a
Friedman Melvin em Henry
Joshua our Furman LS Herbert's blood a
Slav why gabbatha CH Jonathan M histone
young gal
berenguer who do a video gear goryeo
Cedric and Hutchings john k Giffen
L'Orange Imani Adam be Glassman Jamil
cage and juoh Timothy M Gorton Kip e
Johnson Patrick Tuohey Greely Carol D
Japan Nicholas M Hansen's mark a keppens
Melissa be how Jason M Kepler Michael J
harder
Michael S Kimbrel Rebecca a Hitchcock
Jody kerchner Eric why Shay yeom La Soul
Edward white Wong Stefan leader Lee Chi
Quan Robert's seal upon the second Jacob
a hymen Karen Marais Nathan our Janice
Jacob Marcus got'em KJ arimin Jessica J
Marquez sherry why jank Andrew a Martin
Kip M Johan Buerkle Michelle a McVeigh
Cynthia K Johansson Nathaniel J newbie
Arnold why Kim Aaron
Noonan David date D Kim an epoch rose
Hana Kim and Rudy Radcliffe janus j Kim
Tori
Oh Radcliffe Robert W Kotchman jr.
Arthur G Richards Kelly J cos : borislav
t Surikov boodikka KOA to who Chia Kane
John Chow Ely cravat J load awake stain
Alexandra scary kitty
Michael J Tillerson Pavel em Langer
Amanda F Vaughan Stephen D Larson Master
of Science in nuclear engineering
although buccola alpha lion JJ delay
Clyde law
so she hero Vinay Jonathan Jay Lee
Juliet L Alton co y Leung Jacopo Sicario
Joyce seal in Dennis s until junior year
from Lynn Vincent tank
Peter S Lautrec mark a vial Leon Lou
Winnie young Jennifer Louie master of
engineering in biomedical engineering
Ricardo our bro yean wing ma Celestine
Chang
Emily am Marcos Tarija s Nicholson
Justin C mark Jose M Otero and roti
marsh master of engineering in logistics
AJ Bari ELISA Air Marshal Mary W Chang
Yuval maser Joseph C dominant Cristina V
McDonough mark s dinning Brock a
McFerrin Carlos Gutierrez ferret
Matthew a medic our although a young
Kara Genji a may Gotham a code car
Michal be mere this not Salaam Benjamin
M Morse Wong yonder
Damon s Moscow Oh Yama Kong Ming Lee
Melanie team oi stuart jay MacGillivray
Rami M Moussa a lion Adam L McGowan our
June our Narayana Swamy Luke Yulia s me
Nina Napoleon Jay Nelson Sumitra Mishra
cadra and Newsome pretty on rotten
Arouca jeremy w Nimr Derek reading
Vernon Jane I the third Lars M Sanchez
James be
Oh II Nabil Sarang Ryan s Ortega Chavez
when she Robert Aros Lee
William P Stefan Christina I pass
Collins Kevin a shorts
Carol why pests Ian arias Rock step cha
cha
Benjamin a pic such I moon AHA Boca
Thomas M Kweli King Juan Gabriel a
Reinstein wailing whoo Frank a Ruiz
master of science and engineering and
management David G Bancroft mark a Rosen
William F bieberstein David a Rosenthal
Timothy K Brady Samhita semeru Nayak Oh
Eric C Cahill Shastri s sandy Thompson
David Clint see Noreen Freddie Douglas
the third Jeremy I silver Kurt l ughing
Gerald J Snyder the third Steven a fray
Thomas C sub schinsky Richard L how Carl
W Steinbeck J M Jernigan Jeanette D
Stevenson their non a Oh Gloria Spinoza
Stephanie a telex Gordon aye Johnston
Christopher K Thompson Ambrose scam mark
F Tompkins Adnan Khan michael j sy who
say young cool errand evil aid eric que
lo daniel velocity Thomas K Matai Ryan
our Wagner Carol and McDevitt Rebecca
and waba Donald J Mexi Austin J Wang
Mitzi an M Maury Winston Wong G ot
Mukherjee ho take we John f malooley jr.
Elizabeth s were best Jonathan Kaye
Niemeyer Ricky T wheeling
Jonathan W wolf
Stella emoji on Oh Andrew why 1 to C D
ranch on Donnie
Jhansi Wu Zhu Li ke u Benjamin J
Saltzman Nura masa Yoshida Hans D
shoemaker Kenneth Kate you Nathan are
Soderbergh Robert Jiang Chandra case
ditch nose Nia sherry Weizhou William
Taylor the third Bachelor of Science in
chemical engineering
Candice de Allbritton Jacqueline why
Tyson Chester K by Master of Science in
technology and policy Carlos
J Barrientos brinda balakrishnan Xavier
F Rucker Liam are bossy loriann Herzl
Rashard HN Wolfgang K dr. Bauer
Amy I cha Ralph P Paul Marlon devar ona
Robert M Hardy Philippe G de Vilmorin
Lee jung-jae endeavour ready young Lee
Beth P doback Maria who insists la
Marina our telephone Leah w angst Simon
si muy Sarah a Farrar Nobuyuki Ozaki
Allison a fielder David para
Hector AE Gamboa re spare Natalia
Ramirez Maribel Gomez
Mimi Takayanagi Joanna Gonzales Nick
vote lunder Yasunori Hashim hora you Gao
Xue Lara a Haverhill Chuck
Miriam Z look Nina am Heinrich Master of
Science in transportation Ramachandran
Balakrishna Michael J Hendrix David P
Barker Chanel J how Alessandra Kappa
yellow van song Huang
Meredith J : Rebecca
Yoon Jung Hwan epoch Varda Tomoko EDA
Angus P Duvall princess I am aqua de
Takeshi Iguchi Dara T Jeffries Raphael
are Enriquez Andrade Alison M Johnson
sang Gao kuroky Kaido Nathaniel J Greer
fethullah a con Umang Gupta David ku
Derek s Lee Roxanne Lau Raimundo
Martinez Helen h li member of the class
of 2002 executive committee Daniel J
Morgan Wan Chi Li Massimo G Morin Lisa
Liang Andre Wong Stephanie see Liang
Sreenivasan Sundaram Shang Lee Wilson
tan do know Francisco J Lopez master of
science without specification of field
Michael a Benwick Victor came a lot
noona H dulk Megan emic be Anastasio CA
hearts Bayon L Miller unapi Montana
Alexandra and molnár Ralph Ralph are
robots Gregory and Nelson jr. Adam K
Jeff Nevsky David we and win just Paul s
son
Federico a Pacheco Christopher Jane
Saluja Nicole a Palmer s wharvey vanilla
Polly son Jong ark way wrong Amy our
pact itís jy one nancy l Pellerin naval
engineer naval construction and
engineering Robert E virmire JD
Meyerhoff Konstantinos Galanos Jarrett H
Radford Shelley L price Desiree L
Ramirez engineer in aeronautics and
Astronautics Brian D McIlwain Barbara J
Schultz Doctor of Science with all the
rights and privileges pertaining thereto
William J Blackwell Mackel pshah Monceau
gen for Evie MSHA Michael H limb
Danielle s Smith my nose Lahore toponym
Darryl P Saint Laurent Victor M luchenko
nas bear art Aggies other Joon sung Park
Carrie Tanner when s Sanders
Abraham see Thomas so Jack thee Sawan
Sawat Luke D Tomich Mary Belle Vasquez
Michelle Sivir Takeo Steven P Walton
Manoj Viswanathan David a white Chokin
Jay Wong Betty PU Peggy J Wang Doctor of
Philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
Chizu okie Julie M watts
Jonathan W Bob Samantha a Weinstein
Mahadevan balasubrahmanyam Jessica
wai-yip he some H buzzy
Sheryl hu via Brandon W blackburn ina
zaharie yote boom Hong Kong
Ryan K Zeidman Gregory s booties
Bachelor of Science as recommended by
the Department of Chemical Engineering
Joanna see Bonventre Jeremy H Brown
Philip mokuba
Antonio Bruno Diane M Philippi Carl P
burn richard s Sharon Z to chew Sonia L
Tong Jose I Castaneda Vega Bachelor of
Science in ocean engineering Jessica M
Donnelly bow chin Melissa D harness is
on pay Jay chunji Nathaniel be cool
Rashad young Carl Magnus W McClatchy
song one told Bachelor of Science in
aeronautics and Astronautics Amish s
Parikh Eric our boys rider D Robinson
and II do it
Monica L Taylor she Don James KY ting
Stark see Draper Bachelor Bachelor of
Science in aerospace engineering Garrett
a barter Leonard Thorson David am
Bennett Osama in L Rafi Dustin s
Berkovitz yo Nina see Eldar michael l
Brasher john p in right lewis s burger
Aleksei or a a check william s Buford
Albert KS iam Eric a Coulter Tony f as a
Shanna l DS Randall s fairman Catherine
L done
John M Focker the third Nitta are Farid
men she fan Nathan a Fitzgerald
sayfudine k14 Lisa M Gerard Sebastian K
fixin Jonathan M Graham Ronald J fo sho
Erik Iglesias Ileana L Fujimori Benjamin
T Ingram who are Ganguly Christopher E
Johnson Michael J Garvin the second
David am Lovaas Co tomba a bundle to
bow-wow
mark a Monroe Timothy s Glynn Alexandra
L Mazda Nazca a nice go young David no
Polina Golan Paul H Nicholson Brian
Goodland Todd a Oliver Jonte Gourley
Michelle Park
Aaron egg our home
Irfan s peer mohammad matthew e grime
Jaden C Smith couche Gulati k u Sullivan
Venkata son guru Swami
Ricky G Watkins the second
Sasha M Hefner Janaki T wick Rama
Alexander J harming Bachelor of Science
in aerospace engineering with
information technology
abran ala nice dawn in has Strider
Emily M crapper Oh Christopher P Henry
Jamie
Devereaux Donnell a hippo Marcus J dos
Santos one home or oh hey Leo Garcia
Andre Aswang Susan see Kim Adrian Ivan
Rawdon lass off leaf a young Erica a
each Peterson
shooping jon-christopher Rakowski Cyrus
D Jilla Jose P Ruiz mark a Johnson
Ayanna T Samuels Joseph D Konopka
Bachelor of Science in nuclear
engineering Victoria K Anderson buddy in
caramel Jeffrey L hyung Sean P Kenny
mark DeLaughter
Seth s Kessler Ricardo J Ortiz Mohammad
Jake on E&J Parrish
Roger I Hasan Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the School of Humanities
Arts and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements Bachelor of Science in
economics
Ashwin ek Agrawal julia code or simone L
Berkowitz Andrew J Kim Jason our Broder
young suckin Teresa Chang Maria I klappa
Carolyn Chu Aleksandr Kochi been dealt
wrong Petros I coma dramas Hong Tai
Chung rhegium Owen our Conda Jonathan
see Derryberry Edmund M Kong me dodo
Coulson tau M Fishman a shoes s Putnam
Darnell a garrier cheap honk Juan Marco
a Hernandez Brian Lee and Shing
generally sera you've Wong Lily Li
Roddick a Iyengar Thomas widely Maria SJ
leskew Christopher W lights Daniel B
Jonas John isleta Helen C Lee Jin Lee
anna lee Jang Shi Liang Michael J
McDonald
Michael Kay Liebman Amy W mock Pemba Lim
tonkoon Brian a pasqua Nelly young long
rows g Raiden Adam in Lorentz Joshua B
Roberts Yan Willem Massey Sandra CSUN
Duvall Stephen a Margolis Fae H Swartz
Catalina Marulanda Jason G skull ski
Stephen a mascara
Jelena L Spasojevic Elliott Jay Mason
the third Aaron a siren Jonas D
Mendelssohn Alice dr. Jordan saturnine
Mooney Mooney Daniel L tour Therese
Jung soo moon Scott i Wang Peter in more
Jackie M Wilbur Shalom moon Bachelor of
Science in political science
Carl a admin Michael P Mulqueen
Jessica a hall Angelia nedick's lynsee
Johnson Natasha and Neogene Melanie am
wang Tallulah pain oka Sonya Bachelor of
Science in history
Michael C Wang Ivan be Olivera Bachelor
of Science in literature Antonio be
Garza Daryl are over being Joyce W Lee
Jin woo pot Landy M parish th Park
Bachelor of Science in music Mary
ei-chan Jason Park Bachelor of Science
in writing Moana and Minton Marco a play
via Hernandez Curtis Wade the third Bala
Sundaram aye
Raju Bachelor of Science in humanities
Kevin Jay Johnson Michael s ramming
Bachelor of Science in humanities and
engineering Christopher D Beland
Michael J read bet my burger
Carlos M Rinaldi Ramos Margaret a Wang
David see Roberts Winnie yang jennifer
rocha this Bachelor of Science in
humanities and science
Brandi L Evans Brandon our world
Teresa Emma home Raquel a Romano
pristine Jayco Hartman Woodman Bachelor
of Science in philosophy
Adrian our Craig Williams Andrew I
Russell Bachelor of Science in
linguistics and philosophy
dawn M ash on taste I'll say though
Naomi Eckman Joseph H follow Efrat Javed
Niraj Sangha Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the Sloan School of
Management who have completed the
specified degree requirements Bachelor
of Science in management science Davis L
avec Bret a shame
Divya a Agarwal ah Patricia be Schmitt
Dianna a Alexander Brian J Schuler Brian
see Alvarez in June she William J
Anderson dong Jin shim Andrea s au sung
Junction
Christine why aw Mary Ann E smella Ryan
Lee Burke mal Smith
Divya j-bot Jung Yeol song
Kelly C Blackburn Paul Peter P so
tyrannous salmon Espeon Maria in s s
Sousa Christopher Koch ah I look sweet
Bassam
Jimmy see Chang Daniel E Stafford Winona
see Charles Christopher P Stouffer Kelly
V chin-hua tone David teach
Jeremy a Tyson Kevin Q Choi Wade Pete or
days
Brian T Degnan Lisa Tucker Kellogg
Robert Rd so Janice a violin
Luke II Dixon David a van Diddy Alexi
dronov Herbert eat big Charles Q do
whoa Michael J Elvin miles a Walton
Gerardo Esparza Wade k1o Luda lapa a
Felicia Jang Jae Hwan Robert a Finn Jr
Tom c1 James P Flynn Shen Wong deep CP
g'day Anna Lisa L Wycombe
Jacob H Gregerson Michael a Wesler
jong-gu Teresa L right Scott a
hansen.eric jwu Aziz H Hasan Ali Jing
Fung whoa
Dara L Heller mansion whoa Vincent K Han
oh now whoa Sara B Huber ching shisha
Thomas J Heinz the third da she's young
Rachel our Johnson Chung we young
probably Canon young yay Pienaar Kip
Edmund mu f ej Klopfer son w Jim
elizabeth secretin Daniel L young Rishi
Kumar member of the class of 2002
executive committee he's Sean Eunice
Adeline L quo
Jeremy H young they they advanced degree
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the School of Humanities
Arts and Social Sciences who have
completed the specified degree
requirements master of political science
Liang Wong Jessica jaelyn
Master of Science and comparative Media
Studies Candice L Collison Beverly F
martes Anita L Chan Matthew P Monty
Leone Daniel K heckard undress Morin she
won't
Alice L Moy Margaret a waggle hey soos M
Muniz Michelle L Woodward Nicholas a
Nielsen Doctor of Philosophy with all
the rights and privileges pertaining
thereto Calixto a guedel bautista niti
nundi well better Tobin Ellie Andrew W
pack Daniel B bergstresser David Park
Albert H Choi Dhruv Puri Thomas Davidoff
Allen our Raphael a street a deep
Kimberly a Richards Paul D L born Brian
k Richter waleed a husband Jason our
robear avec Mayer Jordan Rubin Michael
Dean Oh Kimberly JC Luka Barbara a
Massey Jenny Jaysh in member of the
class of 2002 executive committee
Oh wittmeyer su y shin Michael genome
jo Marie G CSUN Maura Lena pool cannon
Cynthia M solder blonde David M Reiner
Carolyn our stress on young you young
tiger on baarish to Melchor on advanced
degree diplomas will now be presented to
students in the Sloan School of
Management who have completed the
specified degree requirements
Master of Business Administration Sloan
fellows sulaiman a al begun an ek Wang
Sammy
Atia Phoebe why Hwang Marco T barbiere
Lynn L mu Peter J Bergeron when foo whoa
Peter be Bernstein Eileen yang Ernesto D
Theodore Minh Linda M you
Gordon M bogie Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the school of science who
have completed the specified degree
requirements Bachelor of Science in
chemistry Chitra de Azara Paul J Brady
Jr Oliver J Chadwick Harold G we can in
the second Julia Chen Alfonso a
carbonara
Don way H Chen Teresa Christina in
karbala Karen jade cheng David teachin
Christine L Chang Chung Chung Brianna s
Krantz Charles s Cornelius Neil K
Devaraj Lynn M dovey Bogdan I fettle ish
margarita
Eccleston norton balls Alina K Feldman
Patricio aggregated Roger a Ford
Ming Fung homage M Ghazi 1m Fonseca
arena a guard that sky Shan row fajita
Stephanie eager Airy washy Fukumoto
Jessica H Harvey by seem em hollaby
Alexandra ji-yong colas qu Katsuhiko is
she coral suka Nina Escanaba Elizabeth a
keys Amy I cats why L Kong Eliza Beth w
lurch could 1 1 k CJ Matheson Thomas L
Labrecque chat suya Matt's Iguchi
Raymond T leach Vicky W pan soon Mae Lee
John Paul why Shannon Kenny G we are
Adam P Silverman JW limb Dylan T Styles
David Jay Lynn Michael M Taurus Misaki
myalgia Amy B tisk evich Claire are
Mendelsohn Siobhan L Walsh
Jaime mu get old Patricia young hate
Rome O's Gucci Bachelor of Science in
biology Rima a are no Yoshi Tomo Okazaki
Jessie M Barnes Arthur H Ozaki Rebecca a
dish on e wu g ponga car David a canter
Sebastian beeper Oh Roxanne M Cartwright
luis alberto m wrath eggwin a shock see
gender david achieved a Ming Chang
Syrio reg widows Vanessa J Chung john g
red sloth Helen h2ax Cynthia M Romano
Megan L Colpitts Bharat Sahara Natalie
II Kusano what has Schmidt Paul J douche
Nevsky Bernard art
Emilia see Dominique Hiroki toda
Jennifer a urban czar on a would snitch
Daniel f-fine Meng Fei whoo
Caitlyn M Gaffey master of science and
management Sloan fellows
Roger the choco Roger s luck
Winton home George
Kelly M Hogan Master of Business
Administration Julia Abramovich Melissa
Harris Jack Lewis abrió rushan Chou
Jonathan Kaye Adams Penelope a Huggins
Han ki a goose leo
Susan a one-week well Alexander pilot
ganja Navi Koon Stephen in Alan Joshua M
corn abdullah a Amuro Cindy m KU tamami
osoto Matthew P LaHaye
Alessandro are all D and M - Molly
Ossabaw theorem Jenny
Jay Lee Alex arsentiev a Vaughn see
leaper
but Dora he's not adora a Lin Robert G
hi I'm Jenny em Lynne Catherine Bay FL
are Maki
Mooji bahar JSONP Mendoza re M banks
Daniel F Morris
Misha s Barnum Tara Elma Lainey Randall
D Baumann amber and Murray
Brent are be about Mary s must get Cyrus
H big-league get zindagi Paul member of
the class of 2002 executive committee 8
on Becker
Lorien M Paulson William G Biermann jr.
Angela YP ow
Jeremy bender Priya Prahalad Nicholas
bender ski Tara a brow Lara Berkowitz
Vinod Rao Dwight a bowl aha
Laura a wryneck Giovanni Bonfante
Daniel P Reardon and ba sir Jill a
Rosenfeld Justin a Bauer
Nicole M Salazar Austin nice ax h
Bradley Alyssa mschwartz Farb
Adam Brady Myra Jennifer C Simic
Braga Sidney Shaw and wreak a Brockman
Stephanie and Shelly Lucia H Brower
angel c-shay Joshua H Buraq jennifer k
son
Leandro a burns a meet H or Scott a
burns Vina L Thomas Marta beach Cove
scar Daniel Wang Anthony s Calderon
Stephanie C 1 1 C Calderon Debra a white
Alejandro Canales Lucy em yang Michelle
Carlo Jane why you Belen M Kirino
Bachelor of Science as recommended by
the Department of Biology Stacy why Chen
Gregory s Tucker Yolanda T fan
Carolyn Chan Hamid firoozeh George Chang
I'm Rita gosh Julia a Chang Tim I Kim
Jeffrey S Chapin Jane H my Durham
Kathleen and chase you Tandy a oak David
see Chang Tina and Salman Sylvia M Chu
Bachelor of Science in physics jf back
ow
Neeraj Ruby Jeffries see Barrett David H
Chung john d t part OC Dana M Cole
Miriam L Boone Kenneth Kate Collison
Richard D Burstein Allison W Conrad
Christopher H ciao Jamshed Cooper
Kelly be Clancy Carolyn el corazon
Jeffrey h de la now LT Corrigan April a
DEET Alejandro who I are a vile I demas
Ricardo ku mulatto Theresa a Fazio bury
our Daniel poeple the Gorelick
Deepa Donnie Joshua J grant Elizabeth W
Debus Ellen M Hinds Sergio I Delgado
Lisa and Huey Gregor F Dell Aman Michael
B cry pal ball deep s de lugar kishore v
couch about la birch up Dykstra Andrew s
qg m co Macarena Dominguez Joshua and
Lipan Kevin M Dorn
Albert a lau Peter doulas sue Roth Kate
moong dal Jacqueline M do fro Kendall be
McConnell Christopher L Durham Brendan P
Miller Julian Dweck Quinn s Morel Sabina
s and Eva Derek a print or Jason our
Escamilla Radley G Santos Rodrigo P
Fernandez paisa ceilings
Maria Ferrer Luke and shulam burger
bazan a firstly john d Silvio Rebecca a
Fitzgerald David are scored all Stephen
CG Fong
Eric C Snowbird Elizabeth L Faust night
Joshua and Thompson Aaron Fike Adam
chiquita 1a Garcia guy you Keith w
vanderlin Arielle Garcia Ribeiro
Jacqueline why Wang Schumann Gausman
gender Boris Barsky mark s Giordano got
Chesky John asked God Bachelor of
Science in brain and cognitive sciences
Christina Almodovar a ton Kalani
Benjamin J ballast eric s grape our
Lopez
Sanjay Basu then M Brodsky Emily a
Brunner undress goober Matthew s Kane
Anil Gupta
Gabrielle a Katyn Runa Hansen Janice
Chen David B Harrell ik Brendan s Cox
Chris our Harper Julia our dekat waymond
e Harris jr. Ana beef Olinsky Lynn and
Harold's Hugh faith on Yvette K how Lee
Anne a cabin ik Maria Shehata
Lee Anne L hen Andrew T hence on Rachel
l Klein aren be herring
Kathleen P Klingensmith Stephen a hill
pile Kohli kozo kiritani Caroline h li
robert f Hoffman Dana a Levine Justin M
ho
Rebecca a nice Eddie see Kwang saundra L
miles
Ingrid Kwan Diana in Rodrigo we do bro
Joanne
Morrissey Oh Ibanez Richard W pray third
the second Takuya Eguchi Eunice H read
the Buca Ingham Hilary K rolls Maria
Magdalena
Yura - Elizabeth D rouse Thomas our
Eisenberg Paula be Sonia and Oh Jackson
Andre Sawicki Maria Jackson
Urvashi M Padilla andris H Chopin Emrys
Oh Williams Eric Chang Feng John Andrew
W yep
Timothy Oh Jared Bachelor of Science in
Earth atmospheric and Planetary Sciences
Michael a Barboza
white D Johnson Carina see chase Jason d
Jones Danielle M Morse on chica
Karamchand on E
Jennifer a Owens Samantha see courage
David W Smith Kenneth M Corey Merrill J
- Erick Daria
Kim Bachelor of Science and Mathematics
Jacob D a burn Fe Rebecca a Kirk Costin
V Alomar Oh Paul H Koh Keith V Petacci
Leslie e Koenig's Michael be brown
Phillip G calm Ronna joy Chakrabarti
Pecha Kucha Michael J Chung Frederick B
Krauss Nicholas H Cohen dahveed a Krauss
Caroline C cutting Eugene why Cole
Jessie H Davis Teresa lagos Isaac M
dinner park sing lie Jack wife evolutis
Santiago la raza ball jj4 satola
Catherine a Lavoie
ramie Fuji Christina Waller
John Dean a Haley Cheng Chi Jay Lee
Alexander II Hacha Chung Lee Jung Lee
Carolyn D Jones Evan M lead
Christopher W Kelly Gregory and
lightener Laura K kick ever hang why Lim
a beam off Kumar Shawn W limb Yvonne lie
Stanford em Lynne Jennifer why leave
volt our Leone Arun M Mehta
shall you Lou Vijay pavani
John H livens Junior Elizabeth as jacket
j.r i Erstad heaven are long Dmitri a
roguish need cough cats
Andrea e Longo Carter Christine Rosa
Krantz Daniel Lozano Tamra else Lao
Fernando Luke Lee s schmutz Sir Richard
be McDonald amy m sh way Jose a Malaga
nose Christine and Southworth
Christopher Maguire Carter why soon
Danny P Makhlouf Alexander em talk
Alexandre Martinez Callias Susan ting
Rosario are muscari Anna's Vista Roz
Yutaka Matsumoto Karina Elma Diego HMA
David J wild strim Peter J McBrine me
shot sister Kevin B McClellan Jacob P
sucker Michael v McMahon Bachelor of
Science in mathematics with computer
science
Alexander first shine Mira Mehta Robert
H gray Steve min Monica L Linden
Garth G Mitchell Kenneth a mitten Hydra
L Mitchell Kapil Rastogi Gregory V
Millar Esther M roof Kenna
Anita Morty advanced degree diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
school of science who have completed the
specified degree requirements Master of
Science in chemistry
Audra M Dalton Erica Mori Master of
Science in biology
Emily see Ruiz Jonathan P Morrow Master
of Science in brain and cognitive
sciences David J Clark
Gustavo D Mota Master of Science in
Earth and Planetary Sciences Abdulrahman
M Alma Bell Rachel a Mickey
Janet P whoa John E Molnar Master of
Science in geo systems Jennifer el al
top Anthony M Mullen William R boosts
Ichi Murakami
Sarah J Eddy Kemal Narang doctor of
philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
Julie agapit Lisa M Newport abdul-fattah
a Alda Johnny James D Neilson Thomas a
Anderson sue Santo w nor Solomon Tillman
Bauer
Shannon our O'Callahan Daniel K miss
Mitzi Oh Okazaki William F Bradley
Andrei see Oliveira Benjamin P brow set
all say aye
Keith E Brooke haizen Charles a page
Winthrop Jay brown one PI's and tau
Robert a palazzi
Sheldon cow Michael J pardon
Anna Maria castevets Edward s Park
Rebecca J Christiansen eric w heartland
Victor chudnofsky Sonia Pascal a Jason
Oh Clevenger K your Pato Stephen B
Cronin Charles E Perlman Josie DeVries
Jonah Pete sarah e Dempster Mateo para
Cheney dimitri p dan yeager and pelts
John Dee Dunnigan Victor Hugo Pena
Cabral John Kay Estrada Steven F
Phillips Joshua a Faber press and jeet
pecan Christopher M Fong yen Emanuel
Pecola baofeng Gabriel Ponte Paul I
Glico Frida's Brian t portiere Michelle
see Harris Michael are pres ma Li her
Macario preto bradley m Hirsch Chris M
upon mark HF William J Queen Michael C
chew it
Galia Racine Alan F Hey duck tyler
jamison Tara s home Glen see ready
Judson are Holt Charles J rhymer jr. Yan
Lang who Jody e Rena
Jose am Hurtado jr. Elizabeth L Renison
ho Yong Quan James V repenting Shin in a
way Matthew J Rodan Jennifer why Jameson
Peter ste regattas Barbara M Jordan Jose
Rodriguez NATO jung joon-young
Amy B Rochelle Roth kalkaryn Campbell G
ro Adam our clients
be Rowell Oh Don when Lee Alexander
Rosenfeld Adam F litke and the a Reuben
tsin jean way Lou Gramm see Rock Julie
see lively Daniel P risotto Timothy M
long Tracy
él sabía Kenway Louie Susanna solace Eve
a man's toddy Raymond F Salazar boy Itza
D marinesko Thomas Salopek Alexander
maza Renko Jessica E
Santiago Kevin are McGirt e Edward J
Sarnowski Thomas J McHugh Priscilla L
Seto
Galen a McKinley Michael a Schenker
Mitchell W McVeigh Lisa
M sure Jeffrey C miller robert l schultz
the third Laura Montes see Duncan see
scurry
Stephen C Moss pancha Tsonga dv/dt
Michael P mu no Leonard H Shapiro Peter
you park Liu Shen soon LLL park SEMA see
check the boss
Francis J Poulin you layout wash the
men's own Catherine Jake win Maria T
Silvestri paska wits
Michael seek work Joseph a skorsky
Peter W redeem Nicolas see Smirnoff
Daniel J rippin Jeffrey P Smith
Christina M radzinsky Nathan B Smith
Stephanie L Shaw assente Smith
Michelle L Silva Jill be solely Frederic
J Siemens Sherwin soon Alexander V
skavlan Robert H splash came on e a
stand so so we could see some real
Shanna J sturla Catherine L Stafford eh
ah Tao Andrew W Sudbury
groom Tecla Miriam Timothy J Schweitzer
Lin gen Edward T ty John Dee Tovah Jane
t10 each out gay side Susan s Tang John
L Weatherwax Kenneth W Tate jr. Earl G
Weinstein Ralph E Taylor Smith Tom when
us went ajar on Abiko John J why wreck
sumac M Tendulkar yeah we G masahito
Torabi Wang Shu tiger corn Tom said
Jorun jung-jae n Thompson Zhou Ramsay
Stravinsky Timothy J chin Lee Xiao Zhang
has a - she tells Amica Ron's an Allison
tall Alexey zinger
andris H Trevino the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institution and the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
offered joint programs of education and
research and oceanography
and applied ocean science and
engineering John W Farrington
vice-president of academic programs and
Dean at the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution is here to participate with
president vest in awarding the following
joint degrees Master of Science and
oceanography Juan botella Karolina
Valenzuela Master of Science and
oceanographic engineering
Timothy J press Tarot John H / buckles
Doctor of Philosophy with all the rights
and privileges pertaining thereto
Kyle M Becker David H Baer fy'y Jerry s
fries Yin's P bogus Masami Fujiwara corn
from von Peabody Jennifer E Georgian
john b vu Jared V
Goldstone he pay Wong Timothy see Kenna
Marcus J wonk Oh Davis be reader Keith e
wack Suleman Matthew K roar Robert M
Weintraub Alegre H Shire James Craig
Westmoreland Mario our Senko Michael are
white advanced degree diplomas will now
be presented to students in the Whitaker
College of Health Sciences and
Technology who have completed a
specified degree requirements Master of
Science and medical informatics wish
phonate Ananta Raman Fran's B M Witten I
told Jay beaut Jeffrey P Winkler Doctor
of Philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto a nipple I
al jewelry Eric be Witherspoon Alexander
J and Josi Cynthia d Biddeford Harold a
chain the second a meat whoa Michael P
harms andreas wolde Olsen
Hayden Wong Christine why Wong teriyaki
de carava taki Louis II Wong Joseph Tisa
mouse key when Shaw ruling chow he'll
and K yang Kenneth yang
Mario a year would tisha l young Justin
L Youngblood chang-sun young
Gregoire G Zelenka Karen n Zamani Jen
you John
LAN Zhu Amy zoo Master of Science in
management
James our Anderson Christopher M Anthony
Kristin si Baca Christy a Burnham Chun
Ling J Chen Clinton L Eckhart rachid el
mas lomani Victoria II castle item
Emanuel F Helio Thomas a Greenwood
Michael p hogg William see Jackson
Suparna be Kadim heap t VN carmelo a
Palumbo Karen punch nur Amy e ro bottom
Jennifer a rag Oni Clinton j-roc well
Micah T Samuels Rodrigo Sanchez Eric P
Schmidt Lynn
Eric a Stewart Master of Science in
management of Technology
Santiago Aldana sinning Damien see
balsan Carl D Beckett
Damien s blah see dong Fang Chen
Albert see chin Lewis see Renee Oh Diego
J Crespo Henry a dollar sushi Fujimoto
Mitchell ooh Fukuda Kanon Jovita Ranjan
K Hara Amir a Hasson Alejandro see
Hermida Masseria Yamato chumming P gen
dong Joon young
Toshiro Kihara masa Kawashima mohammed w
con don't grip King Hong Joo Kim
Timon re Komiyama Yuval kwinter Philip C
Lim tech h lo kt m Mantee Maresa see
Martinez
Vishal a meta Takayuki Mizuno Lewis G
Molina
Bojan de david b Montsegur Arroyo more
enishi takeshi NATO Bernard s knee
Naoki OB Jorge Ojeda Castaneda Jennifer
M
Horace's car Aeneas Wooyoung park Jose
Rosario be Pinto de Mendoza Daniel J
Ruiz Diaz a Youngjae you see max a limp
or Lisa M Schaller Clark sue your song
Takashi Segura Kim sigh toll Arvin
Venkateshwara I'm mitsue sheikah Yamada
Kazunori Yamauchi Kevin a man lured
women Christopher a Nielsen Doctor of
Philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
Jeffrey see Bella blander Wesley s Chan
Amy e cone jean jacques de grooved Juan
Carlos Ferrero Ortiz Sachi
Hatake naka J guitar Suleiman Kashani
Ying Lee who's an opus decision ah ha ha
bah bah Nova
Touche grant Sharma
lin shu
[Applause]
it is now my pleasure to introduce L
Robert Johnson the chief marshal who
will greet the graduates mr. Johnson is
a member of the class of 1963 and is
currently serving as the president of
the Association of alumni and alumni of
MIT welcome welcome into the family of
alumni and alumni of MIT our family is
only a hundred and thirty-three years
old not even seven generations but it
has had a profound impact on because you
have been here you will do much more
best wishes to you in the future for the
sake of all the world congratulations
[Applause]
the 136th commencement exercises of the
massachusetts institute of technology
are now concluded a reception will now
follow in the Miss teen brenner
stadium the audience and graduates are
requested to remain seated until the
stage assembly has was recessed now
please join the MIT collar collar arrays
in singing the school song which is on
page Roman numeral five in the front
section of your program the stage
assembly and audience please rise
[Music]
my sons and daughter
we joined all those are days gone by in
praise all
[Music]
Oh SSA chus ETTs I an SDR tu te oft
technology and what comes after G
[Music]
technology
[Applause]
[Music]
you